foreign
do subscribe to our YouTube channel and
hit that Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn now let's take
a look at the agenda that we will use to
cover in this video first we will
understand what an avalanche network is
and why it is so special
followed by what avax crypto is used for
then we will understand the working of
the Avalanche Network and then we will
look into the benefits of the Avalanche
Network and at the end where and how to
buy
so first we will understand what the
Avalanche network is so Avalanche is a
blockchain platform that can support
smart contracts and it was introduced in
2020 by Ava Labs Avalanche focuses on
low prices quick transaction times and
environmental friendliness to create a
scalable blockchain system while
maintaining decentralization and
security users can build as many unique
and functional blockchains as they want
with Avalanche one must pay a monthly
subscription fee to run a blockchain on
the Avalanche coin avax
but why is Avalanche Network so special
well Ava Labs estimates that the
platform can process 4 500 transactions
per second compared to about seven for
Bitcoin and 14 for ethereum additionally
it can complete a transaction in less
than three seconds multiple competing
platforms will have bottlenecks making
them more suitable for massively
scalability decentralized applications
also Avalanche is designed to address
interoperability another significant
issue currently plaguing blockchain
based systems and is very scalable this
is accomplished by permitting
communication between blockchains within
and between subnets allowing them to
complement one another and support
cross-chain value transfers
well now that we know what an avalanche
network is let's look at the usage of
avax crypto technically avax the native
token is a utility token the currency of
the Avalanche ecosystem is avax well in
other words the token is utilized as
money within the network generally for
rewards fee collection during
transactions and many other use cases
additionally it is employed for staking
avax which protects the network then
followers are rewarded with more avacs
and some users stake avax to generate
passive revenue on the network now let's
have a look at the working of the
Avalanche Network
avalanche's developers set out to find a
solution to some of the typical issues
that earlier blockchains like Bitcoin
face to advance and improve blockchain
technology continuously
incompatibility scalability and
usability issues are just a few of these
and by utilizing three blockchains
Avalanche uses a novel strategy to
address these issues
according to time to finality metrics
Avalanche claims to be the fastest smart
contracts platform in the blockchain
industry
the three blockchains that make up the
Avalanche mainnet are x-chain this
blockchain is employed for Asset
Management the Avalanche consensus
protocol is employed then comes c-chain
to develop smart contracts this
blockchain is used the Snowman consensus
protocol is employed and in the end it
is p chain and this blockchain is
utilized to create smart contracts and
the protocol for snowman consensus is
used
by having all nodes operate concurrently
the Avalanche consensus protocol
randomly verifies validators transaction
confirmations the goal is to improve the
likelihood that a transaction is true or
legitimate by periodically performing
random checks the Snowman consensus
protocol uses blocks in a linear manner
but otherwise functions similarly well
now that we know the basics of the
Avalanche Network let's have a look at
problems that is solved by this network
well as we discussed before Avalanche
was developed to deal with many of the
problems that most blockchain networks
have platforms like Avalanche aim to
reduce centralization in the
cryptocurrency industry by offering an
alternative to networks like ethereum
Avalanche primarily addresses two issues
congestion
scalability was a purposeful
consideration in the creation of
avalanche Avalanche offers sub-second
transaction times on par with top-tier
payment processors like PayPal and Visa
with the ability to handle up to 6500
transactions per second with sub-second
finality Avalanche is incredibly strong
and effective and second is low fees
Avalanche which many people view as
ethereum's rival outperforms ethereum
regarding gas costs avalanche's fees are
significantly less expensive than
ethereums the network charges fees for
several things including producing and
minting assets staking transaction fees
and blockchain development after these
things are done the fees are burned
permanently lowering the amount of avacs
on the platform
and now let's look at some of the
benefits of avalanche Network
The Manor Avalanche was constructed is
mostly responsible for its key
advantages the founders of avalanche
discovered a solution to the frequent
issues with blockchains by utilizing the
Network's special design
first on the list is interoperability
the trade of different types of
cryptocurrencies and data with other
platforms is only supported by a few
blockchains Avalanche makes
interoperability possible by enabling
several blockchains to exchange
information and essentially interoperate
with one another
then it is scalability for instance
mining Bitcoin uses a lot of power in
processing resources and ethereum can
handle only 15 transactions per second
these restrictions make these
blockchains difficult to scale despite
their strength and great value
on the other hand Avalanche promises
sub-second transaction rates and amazing
processing capacity and was designed to
be expandable
and next is usability
usability or how simple it is to use and
implement the technology in many
applications and use cases is one of the
issues with adopting any technology
Avalanche is gaining popularity in the
cryptocurrency world at a rate that can
compete with ethereum and has
demonstrated utility in several
situations
so now that we have discussed all the
necessary Concepts around the Avalanche
Network let's see where and how to buy
avax
these are a few platforms with
illustrations of how to buy avax on that
particular platform first is uphold
followed by binance and then bitpanda
and then gate.io well this was all about
what Avalanche network is and its
related Concepts I hope you liked this
video and found it interesting and
informative if you like this video then
please like this video And subscribe to
our YouTube channel also if you have any
questions related to this video please
feel free to ask in the comments section
our team will reach out to you as soon
as possible thank you
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here